of the six Infinity stones the soul
stone is arguably the trickiest to wrap
your head around a particular concern is
the question of what happens to the
stone if it's returned to the place from
which it was taken thankfully the
writers of Avengers endgame have come
forward to explain exactly what happened
to the soul stone in the film first a
little refresher Avengers endgame sees
Black Widow and Hawkeye take a trip to
the mysterious planet of Vermeer on a
mission to pluck the soul stone out of
time before Thanos or his minions can
acquire it
Hawkeye ultimately obtains the soul
stone after Black Widow heroically
throws herself off the planets massive
cliff echoing the same sequence from
infinity war in which Thanos killed
Gamora
for the stone before he retires to a
life of slow dancing with Peggy Carter
at the end of the movie Captain America
travels back to the Past to place the
stone in the same spot it was in before
Black Widow sacrificed herself as MCU
fans now know there are pretty specific
rules for what has to happen before
someone can take the soul stone from
Vermeer in order to take the stone you
must lose that which you love soul for a
soul after infinity war and endgame
we've seen that part of the process go
down twice but we've never before seen
anyone try to put that soul stone back
how did cap successfully return the soul
stone and perhaps more importantly would
putting the soul stone back revive the
person who died for it Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely explained
during a recent episode of cinema blends
hero blend podcasts that Captain America
faced no trouble returning the soul
stone but sadly the soul for a soul
exchange that Black Widow and Hawkeye
made with the keeper of the stone red
skull wasn't reversed in that moment how
does one return this all stone it's a
good question I think it is an every
blessing exchanged there's a slot that's
right it's like a time bank
unfortunately this shows that just
because the soul stone was returned
doesn't mean that those who were
sacrificed to retrieve it get to come
back to life the exchange is permanent
and the soul that was sacrificed can't
be retrieved as Marcus put it he put it
back but you don't get anything in
return it's not like a pawn shop while
fans held on to the hope that Black
Widow could perhaps be
erected once Captain America put the
soul stone back on Vermeer that's
apparently not going to happen as it's
simply not the way the soul stone works
Capra turning the soul stone only
patched up the timeline it didn't undo
black widows death this has a huge
repercussion on the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
since Marvel Studios is currently
developing a black widow solo movie how
that's going to work with a dead black
widow is sort of up in the air it's
possible the movie will be a prequel
giving us the backstory for Black Widow
that the other MCU movies have only ever
teased dad it's also possible that she
really is alive out there somewhere
brought back by Hulk's use of the
Infinity stones without him or anyone
else knowing about it it's also possible
that the movie will focus on an entirely
different Black Widow at this point we
just don't know well Marvel has kept
quiet about the film there have been
some clues as to when Black Widows solo
adventure might be set past reports pin
the film as being a period piece set
partially in Natasha Romanoff see
younger years working with the KGB and
then jumping forward to 15 years after
the fall of the KGB
if Markus and McFeely are to be believed
and there truly is no way that NAT can
be resurrected then there isn't any
other point in time that black widow
screenwriter Jack Schaeffer can place
the film other than the years before the
events of Avengers end game losing Black
Widow and Avengers endgame was a painful
experience and though she may never come
back to life in the present day to join
the Avengers who lived through the film
it looks like the superspy is all set to
make at least one more appearance on the
big screen before fans say goodbye check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]